une nouvelle catégorie de clients pour
cette officine de la banlieue de tunis
habitué à délivrer des médicaments les
voilà depuis le 16 août invité à
participer à la campagne nationale de
vaccination au même titre que l'armée
tunisienne une invitation qui concerne
60 % des 2300 pharmacie que compte le
pays des pharmaciens sélectionnés se
voit alors délivré par le ministère de
la santé un protocole strict objectif
encadrer ce renfort dans les normes
imposées par l'organisation mondiale de
la santé nous nous sommes depuis
l'entendre le pharmacien en chercher à
aider
le pays
devance cette pandémie qui existe chez
nous depuis un certain moment et qu'elle
crée vraiment de grands dégâts au sein
du conseil de l'ordre des pharmaciens
on a discuté souvent pour avoir une
participation effective des pharmaciens
tunisiens à cette compagnie après une
inscription préalable sur la plateforme
et vax les citoyens de plus de 40 ans
reçoivent une confirmation de rendez
vous pour se voir inoculé dans la
pharmacie la plus proche une dose du
vaccin britannique astrazeneca une
campagne complémentaires qui connaît
depuis son lancement un succès auprès
des formations depuis que l'annoncé a
été faite que des vaccins étaient
disponibles dans les pharmacies j'ai
reçu vraiment au minimum une centaine de
coups de fil par jour pour pouvoir se
faire vacciner bon on est obligé de les
reporter à chaque fois au niveau 2 les
vagues pour leur inscription et pour la
pratique de l'injection une fois qu'ils
que ses programmés par devax la personne
qui viendrait les somistes
systématiquement à un petit
questionnaire cela battre soir ni pour
sa température aussi bien sûr pour
vérifier qui ne porte pas de gants n'a
pas de fièvre qu'un bateau petits
problèmes et en pratique la vaccination
et la personne attend un quart d'heure
le temps de
de voir qu'il n'ya pas eu d'effets
secondaires immédiat chaque semaine un
grossiste livreur assure gratuitement la
livraison du sérum britannique afin de
permettre au plus grand nombre de
pouvoir être vacciné le plus rapidement
tout comme mehdi ils sont des dizaines à
se présenter chaque après midi pour
recevoir gratuitement leur première dose
un soulagement alors tous les pays
connaît une accélération de sa campagne
vaccinale j'ai été convoqué à dos mais
j'ai pas pu aller parce que j'étais pas
là donc et après quand ils ont ouvert
les pharmacies donc j'ai fait hier et je
le redis aujourd'hui 3,6 important pour
moi c'est important pour tout le monde
parce que je me sens vacciné il faut que
le monde ouvre quand on peut en sortir
normalement convié normalement donc de
panasonic d'autres solutions après
l'armée qui a commencé à vacciner la
population il ya quelques semaines le
président de la république avait déclaré
que les pharmacies privées pourront
également contribué à la campagne de
vaccination qui s'est accélérée grâce
aux nombreux dons de dos venues des
quatre coins de la place